alrighty in just one second we're going
to get into everything you need to know
about zack snyder's justice league and
whether it is any good this video is
sponsored by our friends over at helix
sleep
first things first yeah it's actually
really good zack snyder's justice league
is actually really good now it is four
hours long
okay it's really long and the best way
to view it is sort of as a mini series
because it's actually separated
into a series of parts it's like six
parts i think and
each part is about 45 minutes long and
you can kind of watch it like that and
be
just fine if you view it like that then
it is not just good it's kind of awesome
so to understand number one
why this thing was even made in the
first place you have to go back to 2017
when the original justice league was
released now
justice league was released on the heels
of basically
a bunch of not fantastically received dc
movies there was man of steel which was
pretty well received and then there was
batman versus superman which was zack
snyder's next movie
and that one was not particularly well
received i am one of the only defenders
of batman versus superman i actually
really like batman
versus superman i like the version of
batman in batman vs superman who kind of
enjoys his job as a bit of a sadist
sort of reminiscent of frank miller's
batman and ben affleck as batman is
actually in this trilogy
pretty good but on the heels of that
there's a lot of talk about whether
justice league was going to be any good
justice league also did the weird thing
in 2017 of not having introduced
half of the characters so unlike the
marvel movies several of the characters
had not been introduced we knew batman
we knew superman and we knew wonder
woman but we had not yet met aquaman he
hadn't had his full-length feature film
yet which is sort of weird to have the
introductory aquaman
appearance be in justice league as
opposed to in his own feature same thing
for cyborg
same thing for the flash now the big
problem in 2017
is that zack snyder was well into the
process of actually making
justice league and he stepped away from
the movie and they
handed the movie over to joss whedon
i despise joss whedon i don't think he's
a good person i don't think he's a good
director i think joss whedon is
basically like i don't like any of his
movies the avengers is not my cup of tea
i think everything that he does is
cotton candy and not only is it cotton
candy
it plays the the really easy game of
winking at the audience the big
difference between the dc universe and
the marvel universe
is that in the marvel universe there's
this kind of quasi-breaking of the
fourth wall there's this assumption
that everybody who's watching the movie
knows this isn't real and it's a
superhero movie so they can make
self-referential jokes that you would
never get
in real life under any circumstances the
dc movies assume that they are in fact
their own
universe and that you have to occupy
that universe sort of like game of
thrones or lord of the rings
and so once you're in the universe
nobody treats anything
in the movies like it's a joke in the
way that they would in a marvel movie
where they're treating everything
that's happening as though it's a joke
right existential threats to humanity
and the marvel movies are treated as
like
well haha isn't this funny the city is
flying we're fighting an army of robots
and i have a bow and arrow none of this
makes sense whereas in the dc universe
they're treated as existential threats
to humanity makes them a lot darker
makes them a lot more serious and this
is why i've been a big dc fan for a very
long time because frankly
self-referential ironic humor
is not generally my cup of tea okay so
they make justice league with joss
whedon and he proceeds to absolutely gut
the script
he proceeds to cut like two hours
from the movie and redo a bunch of it
reshoot a bunch of it
and when the movie comes out nobody's
happy with it ben affleck is really
unhappy with it henry cavill
is deeply unhappy with it like nobody
wants to be associated with the film in
fact there's an anecdote that came out
where christopher nolan
and zack snyder's wife actually saw
justice league and they said to zack
snyder it is our mission in life that
you never have to subject ourselves to
this film because the film had been so
mutilated
when it came out i panned it i'm not so
much of a dc homer that i can't
acknowledge a piece of dog crap when i
see it the original justice league is
truly an
awful movie surpassing its awfulness
only by the first suicide squad which is
really really bad as well
what we some kind of suicide squad
after the original justice league comes
out in 2017
there are these rumblings that zack
snyder actually had put together a lot
more film and that there's a bunch of
films sort of on the cutting room floor
that there was this script
and zex snyder begins putting out these
little snippets
of what justice league was supposed to
look like and people get really into
this
and so online there's this whole move to
release the snyder cut
i will admit that i'm one of the people
who was tweeting out hashtag release the
snyder cut
because i kind of like zack snyder's
work one of the things about zack snyder
that you really see in this movie and in
all of his other movies that have to do
with comic books
is his movies actually look like graphic
novels which is super cool
if you freeze frame anything from a
marvel movie it's not radically
different from
what you'd see on buffy the vampire
slayer because everything kind of looks
like joss whedon
it almost looks like a tv movie in
certain ways but everything in the zack
snyder movie if you just freeze frame it
if you just pause it
it looks like it's a panel from a
graphic novel in the same way that 300
looks like a panel from a graphic novel
or watchmen looks like a panel from a
graphic novel
which is really kind of cool as a fan of
the graphic novels this starts to trend
it becomes a thing
and then a couple of years ago hbo max
and warner brothers decided that they
were going to give
zack snyder some 70 million dollars to
basically go remake the movie and he
goes in and remakes the movie hbo max
launches it over the course of the last
week
and let me just say the movie's really
good it's really good
so it does all the things that the
original justice league does not first
of all it actually introduces
cyborg there are accusations when
cyborg's character became basically an
afterthought who said booyah
in the original justice league booyah
that that had been done because of race
and maybe that's right maybe that's
wrong i will tell you that cyborg
actually has an entire storyline that is
rather critical
to the justice league frame here the
flash
is in it for like five seconds in the
original justice league and his main job
is to for some reason move civilians out
of the way
in this sort of nuclear radiation
infused
area of russia which is a super joss
whedon thing right josh whedon the thing
about the marvel universe is it never
comes to grips with the fact that actual
people get damaged so the dc universe
and particularly this trilogy is
actually all about the externalities
that happen
when gods come to earth right if you
watch man of steel
at the very end of man of steel when
superman is fighting god they're
throwing each other through buildings
thousands of people are dying and in
fact that is the premise for batman vs
superman is that batman sees that these
buildings are collapsing he has friends
who have died in those buildings and so
he's pissed off at superman
he's saying why have you been given
these godlike powers why are we trusting
you to do the right thing
when you had this fight with this guy in
the city and killed thousands of people
so the costs to humanity at large are
actually being taken into account
in the dc universe whereas in the marvel
universe everything is just sort of
elided
when these people are bashing the crap
out of each other in the middle of a
major city
everybody is somehow okay okay so joss
whedon kind of lightens it up he does
this jokey hokey kind of thing with the
original justice league
do you bleed
oh something is definitely bleeding none
of that in the new
zack snyder film we'll get to more of
this in just one second but you all know
my sleep quality
is excellent the only problem is my kids
wake me up too early which is why i need
a great mattress because when i am
asleep it better be excellent sleep and
that means i need a mattress made just
for me
and that's where helix sleep comes in
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
somebody else with helix you're getting
a mattress you know will be perfect for
the way you sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that they
have several different mattress models
to choose from
they've got soft medium firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks it's been awesome getting unboxing
videos from so many of you who found the
helix mattress of your dreams so
if you are looking for a mattress you
take the quiz or the mattress that
you're matched to the mattress comes
right to your door shipped for free
you don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again helix is awesome but you
don't need to take my word for it helix
was awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gq and wired
magazine
so just go to helixsleep.com ben take
that two-minute sleep quiz they will
match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you
the best sleep of your life helix sleep
has a 10 year warranty that is a
long warranty you get to try it out for
a hundred nights risk freeze you really
have nothing to lose they'll even pick
it up for you if you don't love it but
you
absolutely will i know because my wife
and i sleep on a helix sleep mattress
and right now
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders that's a fantastic deal
plus
you get two free pillows for our
listeners at helix sleep.com
ben that's helix sleep.com so
you get the flash actually doing things
that are meaningful in fact maybe the
most important thing that happens in
this movie
is a moment when the flash actually has
to reverse time right as opposed to
he's literally just running around
pushing people out of the way that is
not what the flash does right he has to
access the speed force and he has to
channel his energy in in a couple of
different ways so that's really cool
batman and wonder woman's relationship
which is always kind of interesting is
is good in this there's a real resonance
when superman comes back
so you'll remember that superman dies at
the end of batman versus superman and
there's sort of this implication like he
might be alive at the end of batman
versus superman
well in justice league they bring him
back to life about
an hour and 15 through the film so he's
dead and then he's alive and that all
happens within about an hour and 15.
here because the film is so long
superman only really makes his
reappearance about two-thirds of the way
through the film so you have
this entire first part of the film where
the justice league gets together and
they clearly can't handle the villain
steppenwolf so this is the other part
that actually matters so steppenwolf
in the last film is just stock movie
character like you just he's stock movie
villain he's the same as every other
movie villain here you actually
understand his role
in the dc cinematic universe right you
actually understand that he is
supposed to be sort of the bad
right-hand man for darkseid
all you get in the original justice
league by the way is a couple of weird
throwaway references to darkseid
including a vision from batman that
clearly comes from snyder's universe
darkseid is the bad guy lurking in the
wings here and the whole battle of
justice league is fighting to stop
steppenwolf
so that he can't unite these mother
boxes and bring dark side to earth so
the whole thing is to stave off
the arrival of darkseid also steppenwolf
throughout the movies is not like
unbelievably powerful and kind of looks
bad in the original justice league
the remake of justice league he actually
looks pretty cool steppenwolf is a cool
looking creature he's a cool looking
character and again he has this sort of
weird darth vader to the emperor
relationship that he has with darkseid
that is constantly a touchstone to the
film so you know what steppenwolf is
doing why he's doing it you know why
people are doing what they're doing
justice league making no sense
because none of the backstories for any
of the characters were told so you get
barry's backstory in this the flash
you get cyborg's backstory in this
victor you get
steppenwolf's backstory in this
originally in the joss whedon version
the crappy version
this was made for widescreen this one is
made in 4-3 because it was made for imax
there's a conversation that happens
between lois lane and between
martha kent right clark's adoptive
mother and
in the joss whedon version it looks like
they filmed it as someone online said on
the set of the office
in zack snyder's justice league it's
darkly lit it's supposed to convey the
mood
they're using scuro like it actually
looks like a piece of art
all of that is to say that the movie is
actually really good and then it ends
with this epilogue this sort of
tantalizing epilogue where they flash
forward into the future batman's having
a dream
and in the future lois is dead superman
has
gone bad it appears that some members of
the justice league are just
not there at all and so he sets up this
whole other universe that they're ready
to go to
right what is supposed to happen next
what what comes next frankly it makes
everybody want the zack snyder universe
so
i know warner brothers has decided to
move in a different direction warner
brothers is saying that what they
actually want is a blue beetle movie
what warner brothers is saying is that
they desperately need the tahasi coat
superman which makes perfect sense the
guy who thinks that america's
systemically racist should definitely be
writing the all-american hero who stands
for truth justice in the american way
makes absolute perfect sense if you're a
crazy person so warner brothers has
decided to move away from this even
though
by all measures i mean from rotten
tomatoes to the number of people who
viewed this on hbo max this is actually
rather a major hit i mean honestly like
big congratulations to zack snyder
because
he's been beat up by the critics a lot
and i think very unfairly in certain
cases again i'm a defender of batman vs
superman particularly the extended
version which is quite good it is a
return in some ways to something that
used to be really good about hollywood
which was directors having control
of their own properties directors really
being able to
make their imprint on a film joss whedon
is like the tv director who they bring
in from the wings to
kind of slap dash something together and
then throw it out there
but snyder is a director and you may not
like what he's doing but he's doing
something unique
and that i really appreciate if you
haven't watched it it's
definitely worth the watch it's a lot of
fun and congratulations to zack snyder
and to the people who decided to fund
this sort of quixotic enterprise which
ends up being kind of a hit